family let's cross over to them should
we simon and amanda richards
are here hello to you you can't knock
that smile off your faces can you
no we really can't i think it's painted
on permanently now he's only 18.
how how do you think he would have been
with the nerves
uh we've managed to speak to him briefly
um and he
he said he was uh extremely nervous
beforehand which is great because i've
managed to watch the race back and i
thought he looked really
cool and calm when they walked out on
poolside but he said he was he was
really nervous
um but he handled it really well he was
doing a classic swan impression i think
yeah
[Laughter]
um it's hard for you not to be there in
person
what was it like watching him you must
have felt every stroke
yeah i think i think we really did it
has been really tricky this year
not being able to be a part of the
trials not being able to go out there
and watch him
compete and that's been really difficult
it's made it feel very distanced um
and it's very strange just watching it
on a television but um
we we've said all along haven't we that
if it meant that that the games could go
ahead and he could still take part we
would take that every single time so
yeah it's kind of still a little bit
surreal for us isn't it i think we just
can't wait to get our hands on him
absolutely the important part was that
he got a chance to be there and he got a
chance to compete and as much as we'd
have loved to have been there
actually him being there is far more
important than us being there
and he was a fingernail away from a
world record
yeah um watch this space that i i'm
an amazing group of young lads there
they're real fantastic bunch of guys
um and as much as it's wonderful it's
brilliant it's fantastic
i know they're going to be really
frustrated that they didn't take the
world record
um but they were 300s are away and they
can go a lot quicker than that so it'll
come
mom tell us about him training in a
paddling pool
yeah when uh when we went to lockdown
last year he was uh at the royal
wolverhampton school and of course all
school pools had to be closed
so um we came across um a dutch swimmer
i think i can't remember
you said her name sharon van ruen darwin
i'm rundolph
and she put up small paddling pool in
her garden and was using a bungee rope
so
that gave us the inspiration and then we
found a massive three meter by two meter
overground pool for the garden which um
wrecked my garden i have to say
but it had to be deep because you've got
such long arms and a big wingspan so we
had to make sure it was a really deep
one
and then we we fixed the with the help
of simon's dad we fixed a bungee rope to
the garage wall
and then and he swam against that using
that as resistance but then
we had a few issues with that snapping
occasionally and thankfully that
thankfully garage wall is still standing
though so
what about when he was younger dad who
used to take him to the pool who used to
get up early to have to do that
car run
when he was uh very little we we both
did that and my mum and dad helped a lot
as well
um and you know you never think back
then
that you're one then they end up
speaking to you guys
on on the telly and talking about him
being an olympic champion but
it's a team game you know you the kids
love being in the water they just love
going backwards and forwards up and down
that black line on the bottom of the
pool and
our jobs as parents is just to support
them isn't it and give them every
opportunity to do whatever it is they're
gonna do
there are yeah there are lots of um swim
parents out there who
day in day out will get up at the
cracker door and take their children
swimming
and then drop them off to school and
then go to work themselves and then come
back and do the same thing in the
evening
so there's lots of unsung heroes out
there that do that to help their
children achieve their dreams so yeah
yeah who would have thought who would
have thought
that he was going to be olympic champion
certainly not 18. um you know we when
when tokyo was on its way we were sort
of like um tokyo might be a bit you
might be a bit young for that you know
you might not make that one
um but uh i think the years of delay has
has actually worked in his favor
so it's been amazing he's been able to
go to this games and get this one under
his belt before he goes to paris
hopefully
in three years time yeah and before that
is he taking part in the commonwealth
games in birmingham
uh that'll certainly be the plan right
and he's he's fit and healthy he'll be
representing wales next year which is
fantastic obviously
a home games um that'll be wonderful
because
whilst um obviously he'll be swimming
for wales not england it
the home nations will all get fantastic
response from the crowd i'm sure
so that's a wonderful experience to be
part of um and that'll then build into
the worlds after that and then um
touchwood
um paris yeah and they worked together
incredibly well as a team
as we saw i mean they were flipping
miles ahead weren't they
yeah they were they were yeah for me
after watching them at trials um back in
april
in london um it was clear they were all
in fantastic
shape and in fantastic form um i'll be
perfectly honest
i was really comfortable this morning
which is probably the first time ever i
knew they were going to win
it was whether they were going to break
the world record or not um and they
missed it by a fraction
um it's a wonderful wonderful group of
people british women and team gb have
put a fantastic team together
all of the coaches the support staff
everything that sits around it
has just produced the most wonderful
results and what would you say to
parents or families listening at the
moment who want to be
you in three years time
[Laughter]
just just support your children make
sure that they love it um
because this these sports and competing
at this level
is way too hard if you don't enjoy it so
that for me would be
my main piece of advice make sure they
enjoy it except that they're gonna have
ups and downs and and don't panic about
the downs although i'm still really
rubbish at that
um and and just you know just be there
and help them to achieve whatever
level they they are supposed to achieve
yeah
since matt's been about um 10k i i've
had three
rules with him and the number one rule
it's not specifically to women i think
it's for
for all youngsters number one is enjoy
it because if they're not enjoying it
it's too hard so if they can manage to
do number one and enjoy it number two
is work hard because nobody gets given
anything for free
so if you're enjoying it and you're
working hard number three is listen to
your coaches
um and i've said that to matt the last
week while he's been in tokyo it's
exactly the same thing
enjoy it work hard and listen to your
coaches
yeah i'm not guaranteeing that with my
rule of three i'm just clarifying
congratulations get some sleep at some
stage once that adrenaline starts to ebb
away it's lovely to speak to you thank
you
thank you so much